نصف انتصار مع انه احتفال كامل لدى اركان
التحالف الامل الذي يقوده انور ابراهيم
لكن التشكيله حكومه يتطلب مراثون سياسيا
اخر لضمان تاييد اربعين نائبا برلمانيا
يضافنا لاكثر من 80 مقعدا حصل عليها تحالف
الامل
لقد تمكنا من الحصول على تاييد اغلبيه
اعضاء البرلماني لتشكيل حكومه باغلبيه
بسيطه وهذا يخضع للعمليه المعتاده
بتقديمها لجلاله الملك ومناقشتها لاتخاذ
القرار النهائي
احزاب قوميه ودينيه منضويه تحت لواء
التحالف العقد الوطني حقق التقدبا غير
مسبوق في هذه الانتخابات واذ يحاصر الوقت
اكبر تكتلين في البرلمان الجديد لحشد
تاييد نصف اعضائه على الاقل بات رهانهما
ينصب على كسب تاييد احزاب القسم الشرقي من
البلاد
مع الاحزاب المحليه
الانتخابات برموز سياسيه وتاريخيه كبيره
مثل مهادير محمد الذي حكم البلاد فترتين
تجاوزت مدتهما 24 عاما
وسقط حزب المنظمه الملاويه القوميه
المتحده امنه عن عرش السلطه الذي اعتناه
اكثر من سته عقود
عليهم الدخول في تحالفات اذا ارادوا ان
يكونوا في الحكومه اما اذا قرر امنوا ان
يكون في المعارضه فلم مجال للتحالف لكن
الخطر يكون في انه لا يوجد حزب قادر على
تشكيل حكومه بمفرده
الانتخابات اربع كتب
الاسلاميه الذي تجاوزت حصته 44 مقعدا
لتكون الاعلى في
يرفض العمل مع من يتهمهم بتبني اذكار
ليبراليه غربيه وتقف احزاب ملايويه على
طرفي نقيض مع حزب العمل الديمقراطي الذي
يهيمن عليه ذوي الاصول الصينيه والذي دابت
احزاب قوميه ملاويه على التحذير من
التعاظم نفوذه
برلمان معلق وعداله صعبه افرزتها
الانتخابات وعلى اساسها ماليزيا تفكيكها
ومع هذا المشهد المعقد يبقى امام ملك
البلاد ان يقرر من يحفظ بثقته لتشكيل
الحكومه
سامر علاوي الجزيره والالمبور